in this segment we will discuss what the
sequence is and what it means for a
sequence to converge so a sequence is
nothing but some collection of elements
that are coming out of some set and that
collection of elements is indexed by the
natural numbers we often use the
notation and we say that we have a
sequence a I or sometimes we use the
notation that we have a sequence of this
kind to emphasize the fact that it's a
sequence and not just a single number
and what we mean by this is that we have
I an index that runs over the natural
numbers which is the set of positive
integers and each a I is an element of
some set in many cases the set is going
to be just the real line in which case
we're dealing with a sequence of real
numbers but it is also possible that the
set over which our sequence takes values
is Euclidean space and dimensional space
in which case were dealing with the
sequence of vectors but it also could be
any other kind of set now the definition
that I gave you may still be a little
vague you may wonder how a mathematician
would define formally a sequence
formally what a sequence is is just a
function that to any natural number
associates an element of s in particular
if we evaluate the function f at some
argument I this gives us the ithe
element of the sequence so that's what
the sequence is now about sequences we
typically care whether a sequence
converges to some number a and we often
use this notation but to make it more
precise you also add this notation here
and we read this as saying that
ái as i converges to infinity the
sequence AI converges to a certain
number a the more formal mathematical
notation would be that the limit as i
goes to infinity of a I is equal to a
certain number a but what exactly does
this mean what does it mean for a
sequence to converge what is the formal
definition it is as follows let us plot
the sequence as a function of I so this
is the I axis and here we plot entries
of a I for a sequence to converge to a
certain number a we need the following
to happen if we draw a small band around
that number a what we want is that the
elements of the sequence as I increases
eventually get inside this band and stay
inside that band forever now let us turn
this into a more precise statement what
we mean is the following if I give you
some positive number epsilon and I'm
going to use that positive number
epsilon to define a band around the
number a so it's this band here if I
give you a positive number epsilon
therefore this way have defined a
certain band there exists a time after
which the entries will get inside the
band in this picture it would be this
time so there exists a time
let's call that time I zero so I zero is
here such that after that time what we
have is that the element of the sequence
is within epsilon of a so this is the
formal definition of convergence of a
sequence to a certain number a the
definition may look formidable and
difficult to parse but what it says in
plain English is pretty simple no matter
what kind of band I take around my limit
a eventually the sequence will be inside
this band and will stay inside there
convergence of sequences has some very
nice properties that you're probably
familiar with for example if I tell you
that a certain sequence converges to a
number a and another sequence converges
to a number B then we will have that AI
plus bi which is a new sequence the ithe
element of the sequence is this sum will
converge to a plus B or similarly AI
times bi which is another sequence
converges to a times B and if in
addition G is a continuous function then
G of a
I will converge to G of a so for example
if the a is converged to a then the
sequence a I squared is going to
converge to a squared